i
as i understood you and your career
you guys were on another on another
level
as far as owning your own [ __ ] as far as
your merchandise operation
like you guys had carved out your own
thing where you weren't the biggest band
but you had the most [ __ ] rabid
passionate
fan base that bought everything and you
guys were just
killing it as businessmen and uh
i don't know what what what we did to be
so fortunate to have
that kind of following man i i to this
day i don't know why
we're so blessed why we're so fortunate
to have
um uh people buying music to support us
that hard man but they do and
they're the most wonderful most
outgoing like we we might not have
millions and millions of fans
but the the the people that support us
are strong
and they're they're loud like millions
and millions of fans you know what i
mean
and uh they're just incredible people
man they're they're they're very
creative and they're very um they don't
they don't walk with the sheep you know
they go their own route and everything
and they do their own thing
and uh they're the most amazing people i
know of and it's funny because
the reputation they have of being like
dangerous crazy insane people it's it
couldn't be anymore more
opposite of the truth
when you see the reputation they have
they don't just have a reputation for
being that
they're actually [ __ ] classified by
the fbi
as like a full-on [ __ ] gang
like yeah like gang and gang affiliation
if you get labeled with that
that's like some heavy [ __ ] right it's a
pretty like what does that even mean
[ __ ] man it means a number of things
depending on where you live
but like if you're let's say you're
having a um a custody battle
you know with with your ex your spouse
you know their their attorney can say
your honor
this person according to the government
is a gang member you know
and you could lose you could lose your
child you know for something like that
you know
and it's true if you're a juggalo in in
many in many areas
you're considered a gang member you know
i know there's never been anything like
that in music that i've ever heard of
you know where they took an entire fan
base and
and officially labeled them a gang you
know
and the reason they do that a book came
out about it and
what according to the book the reason
they do that is because if you go to
like a
a rural area like these towns where
there's um
hardly anybody lives and it's way out in
the country or whatever
um and you got 50 kids at a at a
local park having a barbecue and all
those kids are wearing the same [ __ ]
and they all got the same logo on you
could say that's a gang
and if the police can say that's a gang
they get
government funding to to fight that gang
or
however that works you know what i mean
they get extra money to combat that gang
you know
so you have all these rule police forces
saying yeah we got that gang here too
you know
it's not really a gang of course but
it's easy way for the cops
cops to make extra money for [ __ ]
take the dents out of their police
cruisers or something i don't know
you know that's crazy but it's crazy
[ __ ] insane man we
we didn't know what to do i mean are you
the gang leader technically
master in chief i mean i don't know what
i am to the fbi man i don't know what we
are today number one
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] insane and um
we didn't know what to do i mean what do
you do a situation like that we tried to
sue the fbi
uh it got thrown out of court four times
you know we try to assume we're like
this is [ __ ] insane man
like um you might even be getting
sentenced because you have some pot on
you or something
and you're being sentenced as a gang
member you know what i mean that's what
that like uh aggravates the
yeah man it adds to your [ __ ] uh
punishment you know
in certain places and um it [ __ ] is
[ __ ] up man
and you know like this one girl this one
thing always sticks out in my mind
she was um a probation officer
for 15 years this woman was a probation
officer
and on her walking papers i mean on the
[ __ ]
pink slip they gave her or whatever it
said right on there because
you're a juggalo you know they fired her
15 years you know damn
yeah dude